so how would you feel if we discovered
Life on Mars
absolutely it sounds like you'll be less
excited than some others because you're
like well what I would be most
interested in is how similar to life on
Earth it would be it would actually turn
into quite a subtle problem because
the
the likelihood of Life having gone to
and fro between between Mars and the
Earth is all right it's it's quite I
wouldn't say hi but it's not low it's
quite feasible uh and so if we found
life on Mars and it had very similar
genetic code but it was slightly
different
most people would interpret that
immediately as evidence that they've
been Transit one way or the other and
that it was a it was a common origin of
Life on Mars or on the earth and he went
one way the other way the other way to
see that question though would be to say
well actually the the beginnings of Life
lie in deterministic chemistry and
thermodynamics starting with the most
likely abundant materials CO2 and water
and a wet rocky planet and Mars was wet
and Rocky at the beginning and will I
won't say inevitably but potentially
almost inevitably come up with a genetic
code which is not very far away from the
genetic code that we already have
so we see subtle differences in the
genetic code what does it mean it could
be very difficult to interpret is it
possible do you think to tell the
difference or something that truly
originated
I I think if the stereochemistry was
different
we have sugars for example that are the
L form or the D form and and we have
D sugars and L amino acids right across
all of life but lipids
we have the bacteria have one one
stereoisomer and and the bacteria have
the other the opposite stereoisomer so
it's perfectly possible to use one or
the other one and the same would almost
certainly go for I think George Church
in uh has been trying to make life based
on the opposite stereoisomer
um so it's perfectly possible to do and
it will work
um
and if we were to find Life on Mars that
was using the opposite stereoisomer that
would be unequivocal evidence that life
had started in independently there so
hopefully
the life we find will be on Titan in
Europa or something like that where it's
less likely that we shared and it's
harsher conditions so there's gonna be
weirder kind of life
I wouldn't count on that because life
started in deep sea hydrothermal vents
harsh that's pretty harsh yeah so Titan
is different Europa is probably quite
similar to Earth in the sense that we're
dealing with an ocean it's an acidic
ocean there
um as the early Earth would have been
and it almost certainly has hydrothermal
systems same with Enceladus we can tell
that from these plumes coming from the
surface through the ice we know there's
a liquid ocean and we we can tell
roughly what the chemistry is
for Titan we're dealing with liquid
methane and things like that so that
would really If there really is life
there it would really have to be very
very different to anything uh that we
know on Earth